previously on the forest
so we just need to find a cave entrance
and then kill
everything in there oh no there's so
many
there's like five of them one of them
bigger than the other
ladies and
i gentlemen have to say i'm probably
going to be tapping out oh yeah [ __ ]
it's
five o'clock good what about our cave
we'll have to get it next time bro
what's happening i can't tell what's
happening oh i'm almost dead
i don't have any help why are you almost
dead i don't know
you got to go to your inventory for
medicine either in medicine or you need
to make something out of it oh that's
right i don't have any aloe vera
yeah holy moly
i was playing on my own a little bit
just to try to get used to the systems
um
uh near the plane crash there was
actually a good bit of hello just like
on the ground everywhere oh okay which
direction was that was that
i think straight towards the south where
all the hello deer
hi dear why do i see this oh that's why
i see a skull the trap
in front of us the door wait run run
straight out run straight out with no
i did that already and once or twice i
don't need to do that again all right
okay okay i'm gonna try and cook some of
the meat okay let's see if eating the
meat gives me the health
i i actually just took my last medicine
or i'd give you some
yeah no worries or i might not give you
some i don't know i don't know if i
really trust you that much and i don't
know what happened it used to be that
slingshots like kill people in two shots
last time when we were fighting it took
like 10 shots to kill someone so oh
what did you do what did you do
hey can someone make a fire what do you
do
i don't know dude wait a bonfire is that
bigger than a
oh yeah dude you know oh my god oh my
god
oh oh my oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh get some logs get the log
just get the logs oh my god
freaking pile those logs on there oh my
god
the fire is as big as the entire
interior of our base
yes yes oh
yes here we go three two one
oh that's underwhelming yeah what's with
the logs then
the logs light eventually i'm putting uh
well we gotta wait for your fire to go
out i think uh yeah don't touch me while
i find
medicine to revive do i have medicine
oh i just killed e on you oh okay did i
make medicine how did i make medicine
is it like booze or something yeah so
you can't cook on this fire either
yeah this is strange but at least it
illuminates the whole base
i mean that is nice all these skull
lamps we made are a little
pointless now but you know what are you
gonna do all right well i super duper
need some aloe vera don't step in the
tree all right
i'll go out and get you some aloe vera
hold on myself
going to go get aloe vera man it's
dark guys this is wood oh my god wait
don't leave you're my source of light
i gotta go oh good luck man
don't leave good luck
please what's happening oh my god i'm
dying
what is that thank god you're all right
it's not a normal looking
that was different oh
[Music]
guys i'm totally safe over here um
ow i'm gonna need some aloe
is it bad if there's a man with fire
skulls on his back over this way
if i i'd take the fire skull dude is
that bad
i if fireskull dude doesn't sound as bad
as these these guys right now
oh oh
is the water safe sure man i don't know
i'm just gonna sadly murder this deer
for a moment all right man
good have fun oh wait a minute i changed
my mind about
being fine oh my god they don't cross
the water right
everyone on the same board with the not
crossing the water situation
for unlocked as well hey look a fire
yeah man
good job thank god we made that
okay i'm just gonna cook some meat
wait wait wait don't eat don't don't eat
if we're going to go to sleep uh don't
eat because your
your hunger will drop anyway i'm not
hungry anyway we're not going to go to
sleep
it heals me we're pulling our skin
i don't know what you're talking about
man i hired a lizard to come here and
give me its skin and
now it's dead well that's weird man hey
check out my new armor your thigh is
really protected thank you
your right throt your right thigh is the
valuable one you're seeing that yeah of
course
oh my prize see the crowd control the
crap
good looking thank you well i'm going to
not let myself on fire and have a little
look see
my hand that i looked at that protected
once then we left the base
anyway we should um we should uh go
explore a cave yeah i think we're ready
i also had a thought about these doors
because they don't have locks
but i know how to make them locks see
now it's locked
no no one can get through and this thing
just works
twisted good
you want a custom wall okay you know
custom wall
you want to make it yeah yeah yeah right
there okay
now
this and now we put the logs in
and we'll have a lock on the inside with
it
so this is a locking oh yeah you just
got to make a custom one and then cycle
through the options custom wall
specifically look at that yeah so if you
guys want i'll i'll replace this one
yeah dude nice i think we just started
as we don't sleep somewhat soon
supply of blueberries we got so much
work today i have bad acid reflux if i
eat before i go to sleep we're not going
to sleep
what do you mean the night is almost
over if we if we if we stay awake now
then we can go to bed when it actually
gets dark tomorrow it's staying up so
you can reset your clock
there's a lot of custom things like that
that we uh we can get in there
oh just oh okay i'll just put these we
have some extra logs
yeah very cool it's weird because every
time you leave it just sounds like
you're absolutely breaking the door
look wade's all hot about this should we
upgrade our shelter
hey guys guys did you forget your keys
uh yeah man can you let me in what's the
what's the password i'm sorry password
uh bloobs
yep oh okay wait didn't like that one
i guess i've been beaten uh press me up
against the wall
there you go thank you see you and look
at stage
three you may enter i want a cabin
inside the base with why would you want
a cabin inside the base what would that
do
well i don't know look how tall you're
sleeping in this
i can't see it look outside
how many locks does that need 136. we're
not building that
is that not what we had agreed upon look
man you're the leader that's exactly
what we're all following
that's what we need in our life
i'm 100 confident this is the
construction
problem
you better build a log sled then because
you're going to need it man
holy crap oh yeah how do i make a log
sled that's a great idea
uh it's somewhere in
sorry lady but i had to cut down your
trophy
i can't quite reach it from up here so
good luck oh no i'm not doing this again
those sticks are gone oh no
can you can you toss them down can you
really not quite reach it
it's just a little too far away are you
sure that's where we're going
to position it i could reposition it
maybe more in the mountain
yeah yeah how are we going to get how
are we going to get to it this is the
assume ladders i don't think you can
build a ladder you can make a staircase
though
i put like that can you reach that okay
i can indeed
put pieces on this for all that's all
right
we're only 130 logs away from success
i'm about to have a few we're gonna need
all the logs for this
and then a hundred more logs for
everything else
oh missed it yeah log sled baby hey bud
log sled baby
there's another nice deforestation
dude forests are for idiots and
squirrels
yeah man and i'm not a squirrel i'm
about to
oh yeah no no problem
moving three trees worth of logs no
problemo that's pretty good how strong i
am
i can't quite see from up here but i
believe it knowing it's you i know that
i'm coming buddy look you can see me huh
is this going to go through the door oh
my god that's so many logs
you're pushing that you're just pushing
that
yeah well i'm strong what do you want
dude friction on this island is
non-existent
no it's cool but we just picked a very
smooth camp of course yes
you had an eye for camps no that's a
serious
problem with the design of this oh come
here
oh dear dear no almost got you
[ __ ] i'm out of oh i'm out wait wait
wait wait wait wait let's talk about
this damn it
these deers are kind of a douche come
here are you ah there's no hope
oh i'm out of sticks 20 logs in my dudes
20 logs baby and another tree down
another tree down
another three bucks
this is you know actually i'm not going
to complain at all because i do enjoy
just a good project right isn't it nice
to have something to focus your
your efforts on it is it really we need
to redo our deck here in a couple of
years if you guys want to help us in
real life
with this yeah i usually i used to build
this way calm down no i'd do it i used
to build decks i could do it that's true
you did actually used to be a deck
builder yeah
yeah he knows oh yeah did you happen to
blow glass by any chance
i saw a window with some condensation
i'm a little bloated
i think glassblowing does i think that's
how you make windows you just blow some
sand
in the fire and they make windows i'm
gonna continue to let you believe that
thanks man dude this is quite the system
we've got rigged up here
all right i swear i'll get back to
actually chopping uh
what are you doing i was on the helper i
was getting slingshot ammo
wow just poking the ground with a stick
huh yeah people told me that the stone
axe is better than the plane x
i don't know how but that's the thing
really
okay well apparently i'm using the
idiots oh
whoa i switched axes and the storms came
that's
thor's axe please be careful
ah mule necks
got him yes you're mine now dear
you talking to us who are you talking to
yes
yes i killed a deer
good man good work they sort of just let
you do it i don't know if it's really
that much of an accomplishment but
there's a deer out the front door i'm
gonna try to snipe it from here
you're dead dear missed it by that much
missed it by that much from here oh i
had that man
you dick and a half all right so how are
we going to get into this house
i'm a planner i like to plan
your thoughts about this look you would
have had access from the mountain but
it's the entrance is on the other side
so
we don't want well we want to be within
our locked uh our locked
base we want it to be secure this is the
fort knox of logs
you're right you're right man you're
right not the fork knots of log cabins
i saw this deer head over here wade that
you left
yeah and my brain was like oh there's a
tiny
deer that's six inches off the ground
just a little baby deer right there
i guess i'd better kill it
are you guys logging i feel like dude
what are you you're shut up i feel like
the number
what sorry like the trees are a little
further from campbell
like the numbers just keep going down
thousands of pounds of logs around like
an
absolute beast of a human seems unlikely
but
whatever you witnessed you
seen it yeah i didn't see nothing i'm up
on this mountain so
you looked and you were like wow that's
a lot of logs
well i don't know about that yeah let me
just sprint these logs back
how fast you move with that sled faster
than he does without it actually it's
very quick
oh yeah it must be the friction this
really hits the quads yeah oh
only hits the tridomino muscles yeah
those are the ones
one thing i learned in science is the
bigger the mass the faster the
acceleration
ah i thought you were gonna go right for
it
oh no the bigger the mass the faster the
ass
[Laughter]
wasn't thinking that i wish i would yeah
the potential was right there i didn't
even see it
you wandered right past the funniest
thing that might have been
in the ass and i didn't smell it it
really just takes a comedic
genius like bob to detect those
opportunities
this is what he does man wade you got to
keep up
come on i wish i wish it was true oh
come on
i wish it was true
stop bouncing off its ass and kill it
oh my god good logging wade can i just
say that
you are absolutely decimating the
natural
beauty of this place i'm happy to help
these deers
something's wrong with these deers guys
well you mean that once you touch them
they just stand perfectly still while
you murder them
with them i feel like that's not oh hey
sorry bob look at this tree coming down
uh i think that's probably not how deers
in the real world are but i don't know
i don't know i've never killed a deer
with my bare hands so who might have
judged their ai
you know right you know your hands okay
we're
halfway there boys halfway there
whoa hey we were the same page that time
that time my comedic genius was on par
we were equally genius it feels good it
feels mark i wish you could see how the
other half lives here
[Laughter]
wade you're you're killing it over here
should i
are we getting close to like no
no no no god remember mindlessly
deforesting everything that's what we're
here for man we're humans
i think i'd be better off building a log
sled up here just because this distance
between these two points is
uh it's cumbersome we'll stick it
how much six how much does it take what
does it take it's like 26 or something
oh yeah think
21 sticks that's it yeah middle of the
log sled
well now that we're at 100 100 logs in
the cabin
i mean it's not it's not going to work
there might still be useful let's be
honest
yeah two log sleds ain't gonna do us no
harm we're building some kind of stairs
to get into this monstrosity so who
knows how many logs that's going to take
oh god bob why have you cursed us with
this
look i just i'm really after the joy
that was
building obscenely tall things and raph
for no apparent reason
i just i have an itch i have an itch
we never quite took the artistic
approach to our rap i mean you guys
built the
the driver's seat and everything but
like we could have i didn't build any of
that don't lump me in with the madness
that
you're right yeah he did honestly one of
us gave you credit what did i do i built
the biofuel in the engines i think that
was it
you were focused on the industry yeah
exactly
you got the engines going you got the
biofuel stuff arranged
dude i'm all about industry me and
frostpunk when you found a pot
you found a weed no i found a paint can
what the hell happened to me oh what did
i just do
you okay is that a weed
i thought i found a pot but then my
hands were red what did you do your
hands are red that's for why are you
covered in paint
do you look like you that's all i did
was paint myself yeah you painted your
face and your hands
is it blood are you covered in blood did
you dip blood i don't know i thought i
found a pot but now i'm
i'm doing a vision cosplay oh yeah i got
all the logs here bob
dude sick this is probably enough vlogs
to finish stage one of this vision stage
one oh my god
stage one it's a deep and and
uh well planned out vision
it's gonna be a double decker base it's
going to expand to this upper layer i
see the vision i trust the vision
you gotta find the right spot and then
it's just finicky about where you
connect oh i almost held down
c that would have been the eye don't
let's not do that although that would be
really [ __ ] funny
no 133 logs go exploding into the abyss
what guys my sl my sled
my sled my sled got treed into the
ground
why are you building a sled right now
come on man hey dude we're almost done
if you were just locking instead of
goofing we would be done already
your heart's content with the bloobs
i made it i i fixed it don't ask me
i was worried about it i thought maybe
cutting down a tree it'd be too tough no
don't worry i cut down the trees that's
the easy part dude i'm straight up
logging out of my gourd
call me kenny loggin i'll put that one
more tree bob that should be enough to
fill that up i think
yeah too late my dudes i'm already there
dunzo well we're just filling our sled
back like responsible
uh sled heavers dude i'm gonna ride this
bad boy down to the bottom floor here we
go
oh my god oh my god
he's got a skull next to his name now
i sure did man i sure did sick tricks
you know so the sleds don't fit through
the door that's just
in here now permanent baseline
in case we really need to get a bunch of
logs from one side to the other
thing up the mountain that's the that's
the inside sled
i really goofed it oh yeah all right so
uh
yeah okay chapter two of this vision of
mine
let me have a little looksie at the
options
there's zip lines and cranes yep
oh man zip lines and cranes
i think we're gonna have to go custom
stairs for now
what the crane wouldn't the crane work
that's like a lift isn't it
um we could certainly try it i think i'm
gonna go stairs platforms though for now
i wonder if you could sorry i think i
think
bro use one of those famous
thunderstorms get some more
wawa eat the blueberries what's wrong
with you
i'm trying to fill up my water skin
[Music]
are these stairs even gonna work man no
check this out i got a plan so i got
plans
okay okay catch chao look at that look
at that
whoa what'd you do i see what you did
actually
right don't tell me oh look how crooked
that is
that's good that's fine there's no
problems with this design
bob can you hit the save real quick i'm
about to try something
um sure i just saved but i'll i'll save
it again just for
now it's probably fine it's probably
fine trying something
what are you doing how long has this
taken mark what are you doing okay get
it okay good
we got it got it got done all right oh
donezo how'd you do that that's pretty
neat yeah i know right
man secret secrets i don't think secrets
are good between friends sir
secrets all right i did it
that does not go all the way down
helps if you actually grab the rope
apparently if you want me to revive you
i'm going to need you to
explain why you're an idiot there was a
prompt to hit e
and i
yeah you're right that does not reach
that is
i think ethan had the same quote-unquote
compliment for me like you're the
smartest
dumb guy i've ever been in my life
like sometimes you're just so incredibly
smart and clever and visionary and other
times you don't press
e to climb down the road look man i
pressed it it just didn't work
i don't know what to tell you um do we
need a lot more logs is that what i've
heard
yes okay all right i'm gonna re-build a
new log
thing up here and i'm gonna i'm gonna
throw the logs down there
hi you know ah my back if you build a
lift maybe you could put it on the lift
and uh take it up yeah
actually that's not a bad idea i i kind
of want to know how to build a lift
yeah uh crane that wait wait crane
cream cream cream cream green cream
how the hell would this work yeah i
looked at the i looked
the crane and it seems optimistic to me
yeah this is i don't understand what
this is supposed to do
because it just wants to build on the
ground but what does that mean
i'm gonna i'm gonna place it just to see
what it does okay
okay i think we need to build like a
platform up here and then place this
on the platform and then it'll go
through it i think that's what it does
or something like that well construct
away i'm i'm sticking with stairs even
though
this is seeming increasingly like it's
not going to accomplish what i want to
do it'll be fine man i'm i'm building
this
i'm building your back your back door
into this so it could
basically this is our crane this is what
goes up this is all we need man
that's all we need all we need is love
yeah doesn't it always fall away from
the direction that you're hitting it
yeah i think so um i
think so thank you you think you
no yeah you're welcome
oh doesn't feel as complementary as it
did before
from where you're getting ah what a
discovery way
thank you all right my platform gets you
to the climbing rope
oh your stamina it goes down oh
my god
okay everything's fine
well mark i gotta say yep
what i feel like this is a security
concern
what is can i just say that what
what i'm gonna feel like i'm gonna build
you something don't worry
okay all right you're gonna you're gonna
be safe oh achievement unlocked climate
change that's good oh no
give your credit for destroying the
environment yeah we've got down a
hundred years
yeah i just uh oh oh tyler says he's the
smartest among us what do we say about
that
you have to have like the right energy
level to disagree with tyler
so i'm just gonna let him have it
he's very um his position
adamantly mm-hmm okay vehemently
yeah vehemently no he doesn't vomit no
he's
just adamant about it you know we're all
pretty smart how do we
end up where we are
not a completely unfair question i feel
like my
uh the the speed at which thoughts form
is quicker than it used to be but the
quality of the thoughts have really gone
downhill
you know honestly i agree with that all
right i'm going to feel a lot more
clever and smart but now like i can just
say things on a dime and every now and
then gold comes out but typically
why are you dropping logs down do we not
need them
oh you're right i need to build your
wall that's right bob i've got
i thought you're bringing the [ __ ] i've
got so many logs oh
i um i got sidetracked
um let's build you a platform
first yeah a platform bridging that gap
might be wise
there we go dude
i got you i got you i need to be nice to
tyler i've roasted tyler like two
streams in a row now
oh no what did you say last time well no
the last time we did the podcast
about i talked about going to see a
movie with him and uh jessie you know
oh yeah
it's not it's not just hillary's about
it but it's not
oh yeah jessie's definitely worse than
tyler but like tyler's pretty critical
of some things
that's not unfair to say he has high
stakes i watched a movie with
just tyler it's usually okay but
whenever tyler and jess here together
it's like the two muppets that are just
like sitting on top of the thing
like they just the movie's over and
they're just like
so wait do you want to hear our opinion
i'm like no no they're like oh
too bad yeah but and then to be
perfectly honest the thing
the things i would give right now to be
able to just go see a movie with anybody
like i i would give so much to be able
to do that
even those two yeah especially those two
oh my god you can one-shot lizards with
slingshots guys
yeah you didn't know that so much armor
no i didn't i don't know that
you didn't know that i've never made a
slingshot
dude the slingshot is what's up dude
slingshot is dope
i want to get a small rock bag what did
you need for like rabbit skins or
something
uh yeah i think it was i think it was
rabbit skins
there's a rabbit near me kill it i don't
have i also need rabbit skins for the
bed that i'm making
for everyone especially me
[Music]
uh bob is that sled coming back by any
chance
i am up up top with mark sorry oh
just this we'll get there we'll get them
i'll just uh
do these things be spawned these logs
are we okay
i don't actually know
okay bob your deluxe cabin
is ready for business
that's not the slogan but hey there it
is i haven't built you a new oh no
why is that like that
oh god oh okay what what is this
what is this madness okay uh
small inconvenience you have to duck in
the back door but it is ready you just
gotta duck in the back apparently
that's fine dude all right cool hey i'm
gonna go find a cave
i'm gonna go to all right let's let's do
that let's do that together
everybody huddle up let's hold on i got
some
wood okay